- So we were talking about Christmas.
So any big plans for you for Christmas?
You have a big family.
- I have a big family.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Every year, we do this ugly
sweater Christmas competition
which we're prepping for right now.
Oh my God.
- [Linda] Oh, that's awesome.
- It's so brutal.
- I just love that your family competes.
I love them already.
- [Poppy] They compete hardcore.
- Yeah.
- So you go to the 99 Cents Store.
You buy as much ugly sh,
stuff as you can find.
- Good filter, yeah. (laughs)
- Sorry.
Or, and you make your sweaters.
You're not allowed to buy them.
They can't be like the pre-done
kind of Target ones.
- Yeah.
- You mean like knit them, or you can--
- No, you don't have to knit them!
- Okay, 'cause that's gonna take
a long time!
- [Kelly] From scratch!
- Wow!
- You go to like Michaels or, yeah,
or Joanns and go nuts, yeah.
- You get like a bad sort of sweater
that you can hot glue gun
and off you go.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And all ages compete,
and we have people over,
and there's cash prizes
to make it more brutal.
- Ooh.
- I love your family.
- [Linda] I like that.
- Oh, but my kids, I cry if I don't win.
(Kelly laughs)
I actually have
some of the sweaters from last year.
- Oh my God, wait.
I heard about this.
I wanna see them.
Wait, Justin has them.
- Oh!
- So these are some of your--
(audience applauds)
Wait.
So let's see your--
(laughs) I love it.
- Here's the thing.
I'm not gonna tell you which is mine,
but I lost last year and I cried.
I drank a bottle of vodka
and I was very upset.
- Oh my gosh!
- I was voted out.
So I just, if you guys wanna choose
which one you think should have won,
then we'll see.
- Okay.
No pressure.
- We're picking the best one
or picking the ugliest one?
- It's like the best
ugly Christmas sweater.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Like the one you would wear
or the one you're like, all right, ew.
- The one that you would never, ever wear,
like the, like--
- Okay, okay.
- That's the one I wanna wear yeah.
- I might wanna wear them all though.
- [Kelly] I know, I know.
- And they flash, like
you can buy all kinds of--
- [Kelly] Okay, I am obviously--
- Okay, so this one is--
- [Linda] It's a great idea.
- [Kelly] This is pretty great.
- [Poppy] Look.
I love that.
And you're a present yourself.
- And then he's on the back.
- [Kelly] Aw.
- [Linda] And a bird.
- Look, two birds on the shoulders.
It's a little couture.
- Yeah.
Okay, I see how you're selling this one.
Okay, okay.
- Now this one (chuckles),
don't look too closely.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh.
(audience applauds)
- My favorite. (laughs)